pour fabrice epelboin spéciales et des
réseaux sociaux et enseignant à sciences
po paris
ce genre de logiciel sert d'outil au
gouvernement c'est des logiciels qui
sont utilisés en large partie par des
dictatures qui s'en servent pour
surveiller leur position politique et
qui très certainement s'en sert pour
rendre des services à d'autres régimes
dictature ou pas comme il est courant
entre services de renseignement de se
rendre des services
la lutte contre le terrorisme de ce
genre de cas et c'était déjà le cas il
ya dix ans pour à 1006
c'est le prétexte type pour justifier
les pires exactions
il est clair que pegasus doit être
utilisées de temps à autre pour faire de
la lutte contre le terrorisme
mais d'une part les terroristes sont
beaucoup plus dinan sur les systèmes d
coûte que ne le sont les opposantes
meetic et d'autres pas vu la
prolifération économistes officiels ces
cinq dernières années il est évident que
ça très très largement dépassé le cadre
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
d'une façon générale les ce type de
logiciels sont considérés par les
acteurs de votre marque comme d hab donc
les états que ça soit pegasus on israel
année 6 en france où tout un tas
d'autres logiciels dont tout un tas
d'autres deux pays
les gouvernements ont toujours leur aval
à donner sur ce genre de commerces et
d'une façon générale que ce soit pegasus
ou d'autres logiciels de ce type les
gouvernements ou quasi systématiquement
fermé les yeux sur les exactions qui
peuvent être les avec ce type depuis
celle